Manitoba and it's sted into the jet Zone elers
on the wing good pass ahead to bardi driving is
Schmidt he'll watch that go by as shley went after
that loose Puck two valard sent that one through
and Middleton will pick it up for Minnesota long
pass ahead to Brandon Duan Schmid got in front of
him sber Dr it behind the net Ron is told early
this morning that he likes the physical game as
a blade of n mid long shot kicked Away by helar
talk about a coaching bump we've certainly seen it
in Minnesota neita Ryder reaching back for it and
he'll find Adam Lowry and bounces off his stick
he shoots a big rebound and a nice save off NE
Rider's chance as gusers with an excellent early
stop morrisy wrist shot through a crowd off the
skate of Buro who collapsed to the front of his
goal Jets creating some chances Adam Lowry that
side pass up the post loose in front the rebound
and what comes after the shot and it's a melee
of rebound chances one goes off for the Post in
behind Guston that's an excellent way to start a
for Fetti he'll turn 22 on Monday New Year's Day
good pass cross ice Samberg calls it in for
Fetti to the net but that pass is blocked by
Spurgeon and he might have saved a goal certainly
a scoring chance for the Jets they've had a few
there's one B score IO Pinball Wizard for nothing
win a [Applause] [Music] payers stick one point
in this last 21 games or pardon me two points
in this last 21 games from iow this one plays
Plinko on the way to the net shot deflection off
of a knee pad off of a stick into the top Corner
he'll take it there's no doubt and that shot
mentality keep it simple and you'll earn your
bounces off of skate both both sides but things
come down in the wild came out with their fourth
straight win Baldi sends it to l and H just
get over there time short pass and he'll get it
back as Johansson dumped it back to him shot st4
Winnipeg Faber Meandering through Center looking
pretty good Brock Faber sets it up and looking for
the return pass H turned around and somehow that
puck stayed oute to maroon maroon drafted by the
Philadelphia Flyers and around a lot since then
Puck turned over and H up failed himself out
he can't freeze it neita Ryder from his knees
Lowry bracing for the bump from John meril who in
game 573 of his career tonight Merill two jets are
on him appeton and Lowry barl poking at it again
mosan there too this is Lowry centering pass near
Shoots and [Applause] scor the wild this would
be it put the game on the wall cycle the puck
because you will not see this team they work too
hard to come back to their own goenda 50/50 Puck
off the wall how about that big strong men down
off the wall a wrap a rebound and a tap in for
nether Adam Lowry does a leian didn't get enough
on that Peretti will race for it he gets a high
stick to the face or maybe a glove from Harman
but he continues on the M the off back to Peretti
good stop by gusterson that's a huge save what a
now eers will try the left side with the penalty
just about half over his pass that's kicked out
held by vard NE feed through elers out front of
shley but he can't make the pass now he does and
that shot is denied by gusterson good defense by
Faber Lowry hanging on to it back to the line
J kep by Morris he does an excellent job of
that more often than not NE Rider one of the two
goals here today Point pass Josh morsey R shot tip
through score met Rider [Applause] [Music] again
12 to see this third line having success in a
game like this where it's played on the wall and
just an outstanding job here again win a battle
Josh morsey knows when to shoot the puck and he
shoots this one for the stick and this is on the
mark look at the way neita ryer represents the
stick Mory hits it and it's the rebound created
by neita Rider that he capitalizes on go to
the neck eyes up stick down rebound second
goal of the game juel Erikson X took the feed 50
left in the penalty to Mark shankley cross ice
to the do Russ he shoots rebound stop by H and
he grasps that one emotion lots of physicality
and the wild doing a good job finally getting the
puck in the net and and turning one shot into two
and they're close to a dangerous rebound the line
and in they come good R twists back and sends it
back to favor one of his two goals on the power
of the play this year centering pass and they
score Harman took a feed gets a power play goal
PS in four straight for him and it's three to
one that play has to be bang bang and it is this
is a down to the goal line and quickly through
the crease to the back door you can see Hartman
arrives on time a perfect pass from Johansson and
has to be perfect cuz there's not much space that
actually goes underneath the goal stick of heluk
to the back door and you can see that one has to
get up it does as Helu squ is we know that they
haven't allowed more than three goals in a game
in the 24 games since November the 2nd when they
allowed five against the golden knights Eric s
with a WRA around and he is not to the backand
centering play and they score Baldi picked it up
in the slot and it's a one goal game [Applause]
Baldi gets one from the slot trough right in the
gut of the slot this isn't very pretty but they
don't care as you wrap the puck you look for
a rebound if you're in the interior of the ice
you got a chance to do something with a puck that
bounces out there it is from forehand or backhand
to forehand a little flipper that gets in behind
heluk lot to respect about him per waited till the
Jets were on S side nikov had to roll off the
toe of his stick bagosi is on it for Minnesota
centering pass here's Peretti he gets tied up
loose and he can't get the shot away in the second
crack at it I would agree with that it's going
to be fun too tomorrow right it's always you it
doesn't happen a lot where you get a back to back
between two teams a home and a road but always
seems the second game is a little spicier a little
grittier go off the Stick of Tony n rles in in the
for check there is Morgan Baron career high eight
goals last year six this year chance to score and
it's y k and it's 42 win Dominic tonado in this
his second game of the season he had an assist
against Chicago and this is all about the for
check dump the puck get on the body and then Tony
n how about to touch right there to Jon F he goes
cross scen behind the net this is so difficult for
any golender you can see flurry has to look over
he has it now for Winnipeg snaps it right to the
goal poke to the corner by flurry Shack to eers
to the SL backand and what a save and the glove
of Mark Andre flurry Last by Samberg Denita Ryder
coming quickly is Gabriel valard he'll cut across
that's knocked away but he got it back shley out
from but a stop by flurry and Peter Rider can't
believe it he had the half Tri goal squared away
that's close to getting his third in of the night
after Mark Andre flurry makes an outstanding save
your Nappa Oto Parts high performance player that
neat little tip definitely through the Spurgeon
and back back for Johansson that is kept at the
line by Baldi to the Ciro Rossy net side Harman
centering grab by P he just r that off the end
board trying to clear it there's a big blow
SE Spurgeon from a sharp angle and this jet
team just keeps winning and take it 4 to2 and Aon
into an empty nck they it 52 wiip as they get the
[Applause]
victory well we'll see if hton does get
credit for that goal either way the Jets
with another Victory this will be their
ninth in their last 12 games it doesn't
much matter if they'll count it I think the
clock may have expired before it crossed the
line regardless of that the Jets are
going to come up with a big win first
matchup against their divisional Rivals
still go on the play the game is over